あのヴィパッサナー瞑想の場合は一緒にやることできないんです
すべて一人一人が自分で宿題やらなくちゃいけない
だからブッダとの友情関係を結ぶ場合は
必ず相手が不放逸で怠ることをしない
真面目な人間でなければ友情関係は結べないんです
契約は成立しません だから誰も見張ってないんです
上下関係ないんです 仏教では
友情関係 こんな感じ しかし
あなたは真面目に不放逸で頑張るならば
友達にしてあげる ということで
横の関係です 悟りに出したお釈迦様は仲間として認めている
もうこれもう私の仲間です
お釈迦様 本当にもうお前は私の弟子でしょうと全然言わない
お釈迦様の弟子かもしれません
だけど 悟りに出してから
結構お釈迦様は最後かなり敬語でしたけどもです
もう仲間だから そういうことで
まずお釈迦様と友人善友関係を結ぶ
しかし 善友っていうのはいつでも見上なんです
先輩なんです 親友と違います
善友は師匠ですからね
で 師匠と友人関係を結んで
で 弟子にも責任があります
不放逸です 頑張る そういうわけで
ヴィパッサナー実践っていうのは
あくまでも一人一人が自分で頑張らなくちゃいけない
はい 今日から皆様もあの времениは一番短い時間なんです
とにかく頑張ってみてください
他のことを探って構いませんよ
こんなもんね 掃除 洗濯
料理ばっかりやっても
何も自分の身になれないんだからね
くたびれて死ぬだけですからね
この時間で自分が究極な宝物を得るのです
はい 聖人によってちゃくらもれて何？智慧なんです
これは得られます 人間が得るべきものは何だと答えて質問されたら
智慧 親友 親友する そうそう
誰にもない 私は皆さんに出した質問というのは経典の質問なんです
別にどうとかないのです
答えもちゃんとあります
あ もう一つ質問 世界にある一番大きい湖は何ですか？誰が知ってる？言ってる
まあ恥じらいとってもあんまり気にしない若い男性の方が答えてみてください
世界で一番大きい巨大な湖は
何だと思う？私は同じ質問がある
ちっちゃな子供といる学校で聞いてみたんです
みんな一斉に答えたんですけど
でも 龍の国での寺の学校なんですけどね
はい 試しにどなたでもいいですから
じゃあ前何だと思う リラックスに座っている若い方々は
間違ったって別に恥ずかしくないんだからね
カスピ海  カスピ海だそうです
カスピ海 それより大きいものない？ うん
湖って言ったってただ水が溜まってる所
海  海という答えが出ていますけど
海より大きい水たまりがある
普通はそう思うんです
そこである日をお釈迦様が言うんです
水たまりの中で海こそがすごい
とてもすごいんだ 大きい
お釈迦様の答えは何だと知ってますか？雨である
ウッディーウェーバラモンサーラ
どちらが正解と思う 地球が現れた時は海がなかったんです
地球は猛烈な熱くて燃えてた
火の玉でしたからね 一滴もなかった
その水はどこに行ったんでしょうか
それで雨が降って降って降ってもずっと海になった
今ももし雨が降らなくなったならば
海の水が減るんです この大気圏には全部水を蒸発の能力があります
そういうことをね お釈迦様は言ったし
なんですけど ウッテーレーパラマーサラって
はい それは冗談でちょっと言いましたけどね
別にそれ知ってどうっていうことはないんですけど
ただ お釈迦様はこのくだらないことをしたっても縛りったことなんです
当時の人々には理解ができないんです
しかし 今現在 我々は地球の歴史を知ってますからね
あの答えは合ってるんです
だからその引っかかれば誰でも海だと思っちゃうことなんです
はい そういうことで あの整理することが人間にとっては宝物なんです
この瞑想でます思考を止める
思考を止めると 怒りも欲も嫉妬も憎しみも悲しみも同時に消えていく
なくなっちゃうんです
その場でその場で あの嫉妬は概念の中
概念が入れ物で その中に嫉妬があるんです
概念が入れ物で その中に怒りがあるんです
だから一緒なんです 概念が入れ物で
その中に欲が添えている
そこで思考概念は止めることができます
怒りを止めることはできないんです
思考をやめたら何かがなくなっていますか？怒り
嫉妬 憎しみがなくなっています
入れ物コンセプトです
はい ではどこに入れるのか
というやり方はね 実況中継でしてみてください
とにかくあの 1 日何時間でも
朝も夜もいつでもこれやってみてください
買い物に行く時でも 買い物に行く場合は
左足 右足 左足 右足で行き来てください
階段を上がる時も 上る降りる時も
左足 右足 左足 右足 左足
右足 ポイントは実況なので実況して思考しない時間を作ってください
それで能力が自動的に開発していくんです
それは気にする必要はないです
これも これもだいたい 1週間
2週間で結果が見えてきます
成長しているんだと 自分が何の努力もしていないのに落ちついてくる
今までそっちを怒りっぽいいたのに
なかなか怒りの頻度が結構減っているんだな
あら どうなったのかって感じなんです
楽に成長する もう一つ
あのお茶飲んだり 水を飲んだりする
実験してみましょう で
ガラスいっぱい水を入れておいて
背筋を伸ばして座る 座ってその場で
で 名詞は要りません 動詞だけ入れる
伸ばす 伸ばす 伸ばす 伸ばすと手を伸ばす
です あの手で手も入れません
伸ばす機能だけ 伸ばす
伸ばす 伸ばす 伸ばす 伸ばす
伸ばす 掴む 上げる 上げる
上げる 運ぶ 運ぶ 運ぶ 運ぶ
運ぶ 運ぶ 運ぶ つける 入れる
あるいは入れる なんとか入れる
動詞だけ 飲み込む 戻す
戻す 戻す 戻す 戻す 戻す
ここを離す 戻す 戻す 戻す
戻す 戻す で ものすごくスローで
ものすごい早く実況しながら
瞑想に戻してもう一度伸ばす
伸ばす 伸ばす 伸ばす 伸ばす
取る 上げる 上げる 上げる
上げる 運ぶ 運ぶ 運ぶ 運ぶ
運ぶ 運ぶ 運ぶ つける 入れる
飲み込む 戻す 戻す 戻す
戻す 戻す ここ ここ これ
十五分ぐらいかけてスローモーションで実況中継してみてください
立派な修行です すっごい立派な修行
それに勝る修行は日本のどんな宗派でもない
ありません チベットの瞑想なんかは
もう人はわざと病気にさせる
呪文を唱えさせたり ドラをガンガンとやったり
あるいは今日はラベルだけ
看板だけ あの昔 日本のいろいろ商売やってるとこがいろいろいろんなところにありますよ
古い看板がすごい立派な看板がありますけども
商売は全部もう倒産してやってないんです
しかし 住んでるんだからね
看板だけ 中の別 時々江戸時代であった看板を見ることはありますよ
もう何にもやってない
看板だけ そんな感じですよ
だから看板があったんだからって中身同じってことない
とにかくあの この瞑想をやってみてください
ガラスいっぱい水を飲むだけ
死にませんと思いますけど
その代わりにものすごい高度な集中力が生まれる
その時間で心が静寂する
思考しない時間で心は静寂する
はい そういうふうなことで
実況中継をやってみてください
それは悟りに達する瞑想です
それで真理を発見するんです
真理を発見すると瞑想が消えちゃうんです
それで最終解脱に達したことになります
それで仕事は終わりと
人間の仕事それなんです
人間は何を目指して頑張るべきかというと
真理を発見するために
瞑想を遮断するために努力するんです
はい そういうことで あの
そのショートプログラムの中で歩く瞑想と体それを動かして実況中継して見ると
結構立派な瞑想になります
頑張っていただきたいと思います
どうもありがとうございます
どうもありがとうございました
これで本日のプログラムが終了いたします
マエカワ先生にもう一度お話しいただい
それでは廻向の文というやつを唱えられているのを皆さんといただきたいと思います
よろしくお願いします
廻向の文 仏法僧の三宝に礼拝敬し
戒を守り 慈悲の瞑想とヴィパッサナー修行によって積まれたこの功徳を
神々 先祖 祖父母 両親 親族
恩師をはじめとし 一切の生きとし生けるものに廻向いたします
この功徳によって すべての生きとし生けるものが幸福に暮らせますように
そして解脱が得られますように
それではお坊さんたちに皆様ね
祝福の経を短く唱えますので
合掌して聞いてください
ヤ
ンキンチヴィッタンニテワーランワサンテースワーヤンラタナンパニッタンナノーサマンナッティタターガテーナエダンピブッデーラタナンパニッタンエーテーナサッチャー
ナスヴァッティホートゥーカヤンヴィラーガンナマタンパニッタンヤダッジャガーサッキャムニーサマニトーナテーナダンテーナサマッティキンチイダンピダンメーラタ
ナンパニッタンエーテーナサッチャーナスヴァッティホートゥーキーナンプラーナンナマンナッティサンパランウィラッタチッターヤティテーパワスミンテーキーナヴィッチャーユーイチャンダニンバンテテー
...ありがとうございました
[拍手]お釈迦様 ありがとうございました